[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلوها بابرز
العناوين
يعني رجل امن يقوم بادخال بعض الشباب
لمشاهده المباراه بالرغم لانهم لا يحملون
بطاقات او تذاكر
هل تستطيع الجماهير دخول الملاعب دون شراء
التذاكر مسبقا العربيه تنقل لكم الصوره
[موسيقى]
ماسك يحددوا جوجل وابل بصناعه هواتف
منافسه اذا حذفتر من متاجر تطبيقات ابل
واندرويد
مع انقطاع الكهرباء وانعدام وسائل التدفئه
هول زمان
والجامعات الايرانيه تهتف لاسقاطه
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا النشره اليوم من المونديال
حيث قررت الفيفا السماح للشباب الذين لم
يتمكنوا من شراء تذاكر لحضور المباراه بين
المغرب وبلجيكا بالدخول لمشانا ما ادى الى
التجمر حشود كبيره امام مدخل الملعب
التفاصيل مع زميل ليس بزاري
بعد دقائق من الارتداء المباراه بين
المغرب وبلجيكا شاهدنا الكثير من الحشود
الشباب الذين يبدون الدخول لحضور المباراه
بالرغم انهم لا يحملون تذاكر لهذه
المباراه والذي حدث ان الفيفا قررت ان
تعبئ الملعب المقاعد الفارغه طبعا بدخول
هؤلاء الشباب والكثير منهم تدافعوا بشكل
سريع الى هذا الممر لكي يكونوا من الاوائل
الذين يدخلون الملعب ومرور مشاهده
المباراه ولو في همم الجزء الاخير من
المباراه ولكن كما نشاهد يعني هناك ازدحام
وهناك الكثير من هؤلاء الشباب ويوجد
الكثير من السيدات كذلك بين هؤلاء الشباب
الذين يحاولون الدخول ولكن همم الذي يحصل
ان الكثير منهم لم يحصل او طلبه الحصول
على تذكره خصوصا من الشباب المغاربه بدخول
حضور مباراه منتخبهم
همم ولكن للاسف كانت معظم همم او همم اكثر
همم التذاكر قد بيعت همم خارج او قبل
المباراه همم
نرصد الان ما سيحدث يعني نشاهد هناك رجل
امن يقوم بادخال بعض الشباب الذين كانوا
في الصفوف الاوائل همم الاوليه من الدخول
عندما سمح لهم بالدخول لمشاهده المباراه
بالرغم من انهم لا يحملون بطاقات او تذاكر
لهذه المباراه في كاس العالم هنا في قطر
لايت مزاري العربيه الدوحه من امام ملعب
الثمامه قطر
قبل ان نذهب الى زميل ليس في الدوحه نبارك
للجماهير المغربيه فوز منتخبنا الوطني
المستحق على نظيره البلجيكي بنتيجه 2 - 0
ضمن منافسات المجموعه السادسه في كاس
العالم لكره القدم هذا وسجل البديلان عبد
الحميد سبيري وزكريا ابو خلال في الشوط
الثاني الاهداف طبعا مشاهدينا الاهداف
والتفاصيل المباراه كامله
تتابعونها مع الزملاء في فقره الرياضه
خلال هذه النشره
هذا كانت قد اغلقت الشرطه البلجيكيه اجزاء
من وسط العاصمه بروكسال بعد اعمال شغب
اندلعت عقبه فوز المنتخب المغربي على
نظيره البلجيكي في كاس العالم وقالت
متحدثه باسم الشرطه ان من وصفتهم بعشرات
المشاغبين ابرموا النار في دراجات ولا
شقوق سيارات
بالحجاره وشيره الى ان قوه الامن تحركت
بعدما تمت اصابه شخص بجروح في الوجه
واوضحت الشرطه البلجيكيه انه حتى ما قبل
نهايه المباراه الساعه 10:00 الاشخاص
بعضهم يرتدي اغطيه راس الى مواجهه الشرطه
في وسط بروكسيل الامر الذي اخلى بالامن
العام
الى اجواء احتفالات الجماهير المغربيه في
الدوحه ينضم الينا مفرد العربيه زميل ليث
كنا نتابع معك طيله يعني الساعات الماضيه
احتفال الجماهير المغربيه بهذا النصر
الصوره معك تفضل
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالزميل
ليس نعود اليه بعد قليل ااه
بملف مختلف هل العاده الزميل ليث
لم يعد ساعود الهي فورا جهود الاتصال
بملف اخر ماسك قد يصنع هاتفا ذكيا ينافس
فيها ايفون وسامسونج وغيرها من الشركات
التي تستعمل نظام اندرويد بالتاكيد منافسه
عم- عمالقه التكنولوجيا ليس امرا سهلا لكن
من يصنع صواريخ تسير رحلات الى الفضاء لم
يعجز عن هذه المنافسه قبل ان اكمل هذا
الموضوع اعود الى ليث واحتفال الجماهير
المغربيه تفضل ليث
نعم ليال الجماهير المغربيه اييه تبعنا
المباراه وبعد ذلك انتقلنا مع الجماهير
التي حضرت هنا الى سوق واقف للاحتفال
للاحتفال بهذا الفوز على بلجيكا هناك من
المغرب هناك من السعوديه هناك من تونس من
مصر من الصعيد والكثيرون طبعا اذا حكينا
مع عبد الله من المغرب شو رايك بهذه الي
صار وهل هناك فرصه لان يربح الكاس المنتخب
المغربي الحمد لله اليوم الماتش كان زوين
يلعبون والماتش الدراري يلعبوا ماتش زوين
واعطونا امل انا
طالب همم
كاس العالم
همم يرجع لا مشجع وفي
على فكره يوجد معنا كمان مشجعين سعوديين
الذين طبعا يتكلمون حتى اللهجه المغربيه
سمعت من الشاب الموجود ويشجع شو كنت تتردد
قبل شوي هتاف يغني في المغرب او يقال في
المغرب تشجيعا المنتخب المغربي اول شيء
الحمد لله والشكر يا رب على فوز المغرب
وهذا الفوز طبعا هذا الفوز موفيز الفوز
الشخصي على المغرب هذا الفوز للجميع
العربيين والجميع الخليج العربيه
[تصفيق]
الايات في سوق واقف اذا اخذنا الكاميرا
كمان سنشاهد اطفال ويوجد جميع الاجيال اذا
اخذنا الكاميرا الى الخلف سوف نشاهد
التجمعات الموجوده هون برده شاب من المغرب
نعم هذه الاجواء واذا اخذنا الكاميرا مثلا
في اطفال موجودين هون اذا اخذنا هذا الطفل
مثلا راح احمله بيكون اسهل بجانبين على
الكاميرا تفضل ايش اسمك
عمران عمران انت من المغرب
[موسيقى]
الف مبروك
ومن جمهوريه مصر العربيه من محافظه سوهاج
كل الفرقه العربيه
المنتخب السعودي
الف مبروك يا السعوديه طلعتوا رجاله ميه
الميه وكسرته عين ميسي وخليتوه في الملعب
كيف الصبيه الله عليكم يا السعوديه
الله عليك يا السعوديه لما غلبته
الارجنتين كسرتوا عين ميسي وخليتوه حزين
وبسببكم انتم يا السعوديين ميسي اعتزل
الكره وراح يبيعتين يحفظكم رب العالمين
[تصفيق]
نعم هذه الاجواء واذا اخذنا الكاميرا من
الجهه الثانيه سوف نشاهد طبعا هناك حسود
اخرى يعني في كثير من الذين اتوا على فكره
هذه الساحه ساحت سوق سوق واقف ياتوا دائما
من يربح المشجع المشجعين فريق او المنتخب
الذي يفوز في المباريات ياتي الى هذا
المكان ليس فقط مشجعون فقط ولكن هناك من
ياتون من جنسيات اخرى اذا كما شاهدنا يوجد
من فلسطين يوجد من المغرب من ليبيا من
الجزائر مثلا همم من السعوديه من جده
للمنتخب المغربي وليد
جانبا خارج الملعب ويشرك الحمد لله
يعمل فارق داخل الملعب واتمنى مشاركه
والسلام عليكم
حفلات رياضيه احتفالات جماهير شفنا سيده
ترتدي العالم البرازيلي شفنا اسباني
بانتظار على فكره مشجعين منتخب الاسباني
والالماني الذين سياتون بعد انتهاء
المباراه
حوالي الساعه الثانيه عشر بمنتصف الليل
لمتابعه هذه الاحتفالات اليوميه التي تحصل
خلال النهار احيانا وكذلك في ساعات الليل
المتاخره
على هذه الرسائل من العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه
[موسيقى]
ماسك قد يصنع هاتف ذكيا ينافس فيه ايفون
وسامسونج وغيرها من الشركات التي تستعمل
نظام اندرويد بالتاكيد منافسه عمالقه
التكنولوجيا ليست امرا سهلا لكن من يصنع
صواريخ تسيء رحلات الى الفضاء لم يعجز عن
هذه المنافسه لكن رجل الاعمال الامريكي
ومالك منصه تويتر يامل وان لا تصل الامور
الى هذا الحد وان لا يضطر الى هذه الخطوه
الدافع لتصريحات ماسك هذه المره عن
امكانيه الحديث عن حذفت تويتر من متاجر
التطبيقات جوجل
على حساب المذيعه الامريكيه المحافظه
التي قالت ان نصف البلاد ستتخلى بسعاده عن
التطفل والتحيز الذي تقوم به ايفون 1
قائله الرجل يصنع صواريخ للمريخ
يكون الهاتف الذكي الصغير سهلا اليس كذلك
طرحوا هذا الموضوع ياتي في وقت تشهد فيه
تويتر الكثير من المشاكل بعد تسريح عدد
كبير من الموظفين والثقاله اعداد كبيره
منهم ايضا ما دفع العديد من المعلنين
الكبار الى التهرب والهرب من تويتر حيث
ظهرت مخاوف بشان الافتقار الى الاشراف على
المحتوى واعاده المستخدمين المحظورين على
المنصه منذ السلاح ماسك على المقصه
[موسيقى]
للمزيد اكثر عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
عمان الخبير
ولكن الدخول في اكثر من مجال هو ليس
بالموضوع الثالث هل ممكن ان يدفعه نحو هذه
المخاطره
الحقيقه سوف تكون تعويذه الخلاص
لايلون ماسك ان لجا الى تصنيع النظام
تشغيل جديد وبالتالي هاتف جديد انا اعتقد
ان هذه الفكره ليست جديده وانما هي طرحت
سابقا الاساس وكان نعم وطرحت سابقا
بالاساس وكان ال ال الطرح مدام يمتلك صار
لينك ومادام يمتلك اقمار صناعيه في العالم
همم
تزود العالم بالانترنت كما حصل في مثلا في
اوكرانيا كانت المعضله وفي الان كمان في
في ايران المعضله في توصيل الانترنت الى
المستخدمين داخل مناطق الاضطراب دائما هي
الاجهزه المستقبل
بنظام تشغيل جديد
يستطيع ان يشبك على الانترنت وان يتصل
بالانترنت من خلال ستارلينك وهذه سوف تكون
ثوره في عالم الاتصالات وفي عالم الاعلام
ايضا بمعنى انه حتى الاعلامي في اي مكان
في الدنيا سوف يستطيع ان يقوم بالبث
الفضائي من خلال هاتف ذكي يستطيع ان
يتعامل معه بكل سهوله وبكل يسر ويستطيع ان
يتنقل في ايضا من مكان الى مكان بكل سهوله
هذه تعويذه خلاص لاله الماسك من الورطه
التي تورط فيها في في تويتر نعم
بالرغم من من محاوله تصغير حجم هذا
الاختراع لانه اختراع ليس بالسحر وهنا
بالتجارب لم تستطع ان تجاريها بين
العملاقين بعالم التكنولوجيا الهواتف
اتحدث عن هواوي عن ما يعرف بقاعده
الابتكار نوكيا وغيرها لم تستطع ان تنتج
شيء ينافس هاتين همم الشركتين بالسوق
السوق التكنولوجيا هل سيستطيع كذلك
يعني الافعى اذا ما غيرت جلدها بتموت وانا
التغيير والتجديد والتبديل وهذا الرجل
عودنا على الخوض في المغامرات التقنيه
يعني من صنع السياره الكهربائيه الكامل
اللي كانت بالنسبه خيال في بعض الوقت من
الاوقات من قال انا سازود العالم
بالانترنت من خلال اقمار صناعيه كانت ايضا
نوع من انواع الخيال وانا اعتقد ان ما دام
تحدث في هذا الامر فهو الان في في الاجراء
التقني يمكن مش بس بالاداري تجاوز الاداري
هو بال- بالاجراء التقنيه لايجاد مثل هذه
التقنيه هذا الرجل مغامر وسبب نجاحه
المغامره يعني انا اقول انه هذا الرجل اذا
اذا قال فعل
ولكن يعني هنا نتحدث عن نقله يعني ممكن ان
نذهب الى هاتف مختلف تماما عن الهاتف الذي
نعرفه الان
واحده ما نجح به يعني بالطرح بطرح
ابتكارات جديده غير معوده
مختلف تماما عن انظمه التشغيل الحاليه
الموجوده حاليا نوكيا ماتت لانه الجهاز
نوكيا مات لانه ما كان في تجديد بلاك بيري
مات لانه ما كان في تجديد عمليا التجديد
وانا هذه الخطوه اذا اذا قام فيها الى
الماسك سوف يعني مش بس ينافس يعني سوف
يتقدم خطوات طويله الى الامام همم
عن ابل وعن اندرويد فبالتالي هو ان قام
فيها هذه حركه صاعقه حركه يعني خارقه
للعاده وهذه يعني ننتظر من له الناس مثل
هذا الامر وان يقوم ان يترك تويتر ومشاكل
تويتر وان يتفرغ الى مثل هذا الاختراع
الذي تحتاجه الحقيقه البشريه في كل مكان
لانه ايضا يعني مخاطره شكرا لك استاذ رائد
سمور حدثتنا من عمان
[موسيقى]
لهجره العقول وخساره المستخدمين هو الاخطر
خلافات مع افضل العلامات التجاريه
والمسوقين في العهد المطرب لتويتر عرض قسم
الاعلانات لدى الشركه الذي يجني 5 مليارات
دولار سنويا الى ضربه قويه
جميع العلامات التجاريه الكبرى اوقفت
مؤقتنا الانفاق على تويتر مستشهدين بالجزع
من نهج ماسك بمراقبه المحتوى وفصل العديد
من فريق مبيعات الاعلانات قسم الاعلانات
بتويتر تعرض ايضا لضربه الموجعه بعد عده
موجات من عمليات الفصل والاستقالات ادت
لنقص حاد بالموظفين وباتت العديد من
الوكالات لا تملك نقطه اتصال مع تويتر
ماسك المرغم على ات الصفقه تويتر يجد نفسه
تحت ضغوط تحقيق الارادات حيث يواجه
مدفوعات بفائده سنويه بقيمه مليار دولار
بعد تحميل الشريكه بدينا قدره 13 مليار
دولار للمساعده في تمويل استحواذه على
الشركه رغم تلك الحقائق كلها لا يزال
الملياردير ينظر بتفاؤل للعصفور الازرق
ويغرد عبره بابرز انجازاته على صعيد
المستخدمين يقول ماسك ان تسجيلات
المستخدمين الجدد بلغت اعلى مستوياتها
بمتوسط اكثر من مليونين شخص يوميا في
الايام السبعه الماضيه اعتبارا من السادس
عشر من نوفمبر و بنسبه 66% مقارنه
بالاسبوع نفسه من العام الماضي وما يقرب
من ثمانيه مليارات دقيقه النشطه يوميا
للمستخدمين في الايام السبعه الماضيه
اعتبارا من الخامس عشر من نوفمبر وبالنسبه
30% مقارنه بنفس الاسبوع من العام الماضي
اما خط كراهيه على تويتر فبات اقل بقرابه
الثلث اعتبارا من الثالث عشر من نوفمبر
مقارنه بمنتصف اكتوبر من العام الماضي
بانخفاض من 10 ملايين الى مليونين ونصف
المليون الا ان النظره التفاؤليه لالم
ماسك تجاه منسطه الرقميه كانت تناقض
ارقاما اخرى فقد كشف تقرير لمركز مكافحه
الكراهيه الرقبيه ان استخدام الاهانات
العنصريه على تويتر ارتفع ثلاثه اضعاف
مقارنه بالاعوام السابقه منذ استحواذ الى
الماسك على المنصه واتهم الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتويتر بالفشل في ازاله خطاب الكراهيه
تتابعونا ولكن بعد قليل
نساء اوكرانيا يتدربنا على استعمال الدروس
[موسيقى]
مستشفى المواساه بالخبر اول مستشفى في
القطاع الخاص يقدم خدمه استبدال مفصل
الركبه باستخدام الروبوت الجراحي من خلال
الاستفاده من خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي رحله
علاج اقصر واسهل المواساه خبره تنبض
بالثقه
[موسيقى]
صعود النزيه
الجبهه الداخليه الجمعه الواحده بعد منتصف
الليل على الشاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
الاسواق العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه ان روسيا واوكرانيا تحتفظان
بقوه كبيره في منطقه دونياس شرقي اوكرانيا
ولا تغييرات على الارض هذا واكد الدفاع
البريطانيه ان موسكو تعتبر القتال في
بابليفكا مفتاحا للتقدم في كامل دنيا
اسكراجحت عدم قدره روسيا على تحقيق اختراق
في دنيا قريبا من جهه اخرى اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قتل مئات المسلحيه
البولنديين في معارك دونياس وكشفت الدفاع
الروسيه عن تدمير منصات لاطلاق صواريخي
مارس الامريكيه صنع فيزا هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه اكدت في
تقرير لها ان نصف بدات في روسيا والمناطق
الاوكرانيه التي تحتلها الاستعدادات
للموجات التاليه من تعبئه سريه في صفوف
القوات الروسيه اعتبارا من العاشر من
ديسمبر المقبل
العاصمه الاوكرانيه اكياس بلا كهرباء وماء
وتدفئه بعد هجمات موسكو على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه والثلوج تهدد بمزيد من
المعاناه للاوكرانيين الحراره في البلاد
دون الصفر والتدفئه غير متوفره في ظل
انقطاع الكهرباء الذي طال الملايين
الاشخاص على واقع استمرار القصف الروسي
الوضع في اكياس صعب جدا حتى الساعه
وانقطاع الكهرباء مستمر على الجميع وعلى
جميع استخدام الكهرباء بحدود تقول شركه
تشغيل شبكه الكهرباء في اوكرانيا الشركه
اكدت ايضا ان منتجين الكهرباء تمكنوا من
تغطيات ثلاثه ارباع احتياجات الاستهلاك
فقط مما استلزم فرض قيود وانقطاع الكهرباء
في جميع انحاء البلاد الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
اكدت ان ملايين شخص انقطعت عنهم الكهرباء
بعد احدث عمليات قصف روسيه الاسبوع الماضي
والذي الحق اسوا اضرار حتى الان باوكرانيا
وادى الى ترك الملايين بلا كهرباء او ما
او تدفئه الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
ميرسيليسكي انتقد بشده رئيس بلديه كاف
بسبب ما وصفه لسوء ادائه في انشاء ملاجئ
طارئه لمساعده من يفتقرون للكهرباء
والتدفئه والتدفئه بعد الهجمات الروسيه
وذلك في خلاف عناني نادر بين زعماء
اوكرانيا المهندسون يواصلون السعاده نظام
الطاقه ولكن لا تزال القيود على الامداد
بالكهرباء موجوده في خمسه عشره منطقه في
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك في المقابل تكرم لن
يقول انها هجمات موسكو على البنيه تحتيه
للطاقه هي نتيجه لعدم استعداد
[موسيقى]
معنا من موقع
المحلل السياسي استاذ بابل لماذا تعتبر
روسيا اليوم القتال في بابليكا محوري
ومفصلي وما الذي يمكن ان يغيره في مجرى
العمليات العسكريه
ماسكو
الاساسيه
والتواصل الى اقرب اطلاق نار مطول لتجميد
الوضع الحاليا بشكل او باخرى على الخطوط
التي سترون عليها هذا هو هدف روسيا
الاستراتيجي الحالي
حاليا هنالك بعض القتال الجاري على مناطق
مختلفه من الجبهات
ولكنها راكده او ليست كبيره
لان هنا الكاف فصل الخريف
والشتاء اخترب وهنا لك الثلوج في الحقول
والمناطق لتجري فيها القتال
والاراضي مبلله وحتى الخنادق همم ممتلئه
بالوحل وهذا بالتاكيد همم غير مفيد لاي
وعمليات هجوميه وهذا يعني
الجيش في وضع السكن وروسيا حاليا تستغل
نعم قدرتها بعيده المدى لباربي الاهداف في
اعماقه اوكرانيا وبالتالي شبكات الكهرباء
لفرض الضغط على الاوكرانيين
لكي
يطلب واو يبحث عن وقفه اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
السيد
الثلوجيا موجوده اصلا انه حتى في موسكو
ولكن البرد القارص سياتي ويحل قريبا هذا
الصيف او هذا العام الشتاء يا حلو بيقتل
مبكر ويبدو انه شديد وهذا يعني انه خلال
الاسابيع قليله
كل الرمال سوف تتجمد وكانها خرسانات
والدبابات والشاحنات كلها بامكانها عبور
مره اخرى وعبر الطرق الرمليه واعتقد بان
لوكرانيين يخططون لهجوم كبير من اجل هزيمه
روسيا والانتصار بالحرب
ذلك وهمم
يستعدون
الاوكراني وبالتالي يفرضون الضغط على
اوكرانيا من اجل الخضوع لوقف يطلع النار
من خلال ضربات عبر صواريخ بعيده المدى
اعتقدوا بان الشتاء القادم وهذا يعني في
شهر ديسمبر وربما على الارجح ديسمبر
حاسما او معارك حاسمه من قبل ان لا
الطرفين اوكرانيا ستحاول هزيمه روسيا
وروسيا ستحارب هزيمه اوكرانيا ووقفها
جمعتها
لا نعرف ان كان سيكون هناك وقت اطلاق
النار او استمرار الهجمات الاوكرانيه
ولكنه روسيه ترغب في اطلاق النار وكل ذلك
سيحسم على ارض المعركه
ثلاثاء دول حلف الناتو استنفذت مخزونتها
من الذخائر المدفعيه والجويه صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز قالت ان امدادات السلاح
لاوكرانيا ودول خط المواجهه كابولندا ودول
بطيخ باتت عبئا يثقل كاهل الحلف ولاتحاد
الاوروبي فنوته
اشهر تسعه مرت على الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا انهكت الطرفين بشكل واضح وافرغت
مخزن السلاح كما يبدو وحتى العزم الغربي
على مدكرانيا بالسلاح وفقا نيويورك تايمز
وتيره الحرب اشتدت وطال امدها والتناسب
بين استهلاك الذخيره وانتاجها بتعكسيا
الغرب لم يعد قادرا على الحفاظ على الخط
البياني للتغذيه العسكريه في ارتفاع او
حتى ثبت المخازن تفرغ بينما روسيا
واوكرانيا تحرقان الاسلحه بوتيره لم يسبق
لها مثيل منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ليرتبط مصير الحرب بالحفاظ على استمراريه
تدفق السلاح للطرفين عدد الطلقات في اليوم
الواحد في اوكرانيا يعادل شهرا او اكثر في
افغانستان
تصريحات مختلفه اطلقتها الولايات المتحده
تصر على ان مخزوناتها تسد الحاجه
الاوكرانيه الملحه في سبيل حمايه مصلحه
امريكا في كل مكان
نحن ملتزمون بتزويد اوكرانيا بما تحتاجه
في ساحه المعركه
بدايله تبدو اقتصاديه اكثر اقترحها الغرب
على دول اوروبا الشرقيه كالعوده لمعدتي
الحقبه السوفيتيه كانظمه اس
32 واستثمار مصانع الاسلحه القديمه لاعاده
تصنيع الذخائر
روسيا ليست في حال افضل فهي ايضا تقصد في
استهلاك الذخائر وتزيد الانتاج العسكري
رغم ذلك تتجه نحو حليفتيها لشراء الصواريخ
من كوريا الشماليه واستخدام المسيارات
الايرانيه الرخيصه الى عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
النساء في اوكرانيا يتقدمين الى الصفوف
الاماميه للمواجهه في العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه ضد بلادهم الاوكرانيات يتدربن
لاكتساب مهاره قياده الطائرات المسيره
التي تلعب دورا حااسما في المعارك وذلك
عبر الخضوع لدورات تدريبيه في مدرسه
متخصصه بتعليم النساء المدنيات او
العاملات في الاجهزه العسكريه او الامنيه
لاكتساب مهارات قياديه قياده الطائره
المسيره عن بعد وفق تقرير نشارته شبكات ان
بي ار الامريكيه المدرسه انشئت في كيا في
اغسطس الماضي وهي تقدم دروسا مجانيه
للمنتسبينها وخلال المرحله التعليميه على
استخدام تتعلم النساء استخدام وحده التحكم
وفحص البطاريات وكيفيه الاقلاع والتحليق
على ارتفاعات مختلفه مؤسس المدرسه
كشف ان 80% من الذين يتعلمون مهارات
التحكم بالطائرات المسيره عن بعد يريدون
مساعده الجيش الاخرى نساء من جميع انحاء
اوكرانيا يشاركنا في هذه التدريبات بينهن
فنانات وصحفافيات وعرضات ازياء حيث
يتعلمنا مهاره قراءه الخرائط و التحكم
بتوجيه الطائره للكشف عن معلومات
الاستخباراتيه ومعرفه ما يجري في الخطوط
الاماميه ويتضمن فريق التحليق بهذا نوع من
الطائرات شخصان احدهم يمارس مهمات الطيار
ويتحكم بها والاخر يعطي ارشادات ويراقب
مسار الطائره عبر شاشه التحكم
[موسيقى]
قبل يومين من اعتقالها بعد فريده مراد
خاني
تاعت العالم اجمع الى مقاطعه النظام ودعم
الشعب الايراني
انتظار اوناس
لاول مره في تاريخ البشريه ثمن النساء
قوتهن الخفيه على هذا المجتمع ذكري
واظهرنا بكل شجاعه ان مقر القوه الحقيقيه
هو في الفكر وليس في الذراع وهذه القوه
مستقله عن الجنس
قاتل الاطفال هذا النظام وليس ملتزما بايه
مبادئ ولا حتى بمبادئه الدينيه انه لا
يعرف اي قانون او حكم الا قانون القوه
والمال والحفاظ على السلطه باي وسيله
الايرانيون الشجعان هم في الواقع في حاله
حرب مع جميع الحكومات التي تدعمها هؤلاء
الحكام ان العقوبات السخيفه والمضحكه
اخرى هناك صفقات بالمليارات خلف الكواليس
الامر الذي يظهر ان الايرانيين المحبين
الحريات لوحدهم في هذه المعركه المذهله
الرصاصه التي تصيب الاطفال في كردستان
واذربيجان وبوجستان واهواز وجميع انحاء
ايران ليست من صنع ايران الى متى سنشهد
اضطهاد المستبدين السياسيين في اي جزء من
هذا العالم
جامعات ايران تنطفض مجددا بعد ما قاده
الاحتجاجات في بدايتها ففي جامعه امير
كبير لتكنولوجيا بالعاصمه طهران نظم
الطلاب اعتصاما احتجاجا على اعتقال السلطه
السلطات عددا من زملائهم جامعه اطباء في
طهران ايضا احتاجه الطلاب بطريقه خاصه حيث
زينوا كليه الاداب برمودا برتقاليه
بمناسبه اليوم العالمي للقضاء على العنف
ضد المراه في جامعه اصفهان للتكنولوجيا
الاحتجاجات لم تكن صامطه ولا رمسيه حيث
تظاهر الطلاب وردته ضد النظام الايراني
طلاب جامعه العلوم والثقافه بطاهره منظمه
احتجاجا تضامنيا مع ابناء محافظه كردستان
وندد بقتل قوات الامن للمتظاهرين في
المحافظه من جانبها شهدت جامعه خرز
خوارزميه
تضامنا مع ابناء محافظات ايرانيه تشه
احتجاجات ضد السلطات وبالتزامن مع مظاهرات
الجامعات الدراما محتجون النار في مقر
للبسيج بمدينه
برزاجان في محافظه بوشهر وحرقوا صوره
لقاسم سليمان في مدينه قرشيك جنوب طهران
من لندن ينضم الينا الباحث في شان
الايراني حسن راضي استاذ حسن لطالما كانت
الجامعات الايرانيه نقطه انطلاق مركزيه
لاي تحول سياسي واجتماعي بكل تاريخ طهران
من ايام الشاه الى ايام الثوره الخميليه
اليوم مع يعني عوده الجامعات لتكون نقطه
الشراره ماذا يعني ذلك من زخم بهذه
التظاهرات
تحيه طيبه لك المشاهدين اعتقد يعني
الطلاب لم يهداوا والجامعات لم تهدا يعني
منذ انطلاق الثوره اكثر من شهرين لحد الان
رغم القمع والاعتقالات والتنكيل بهم لكن
ما زالوا مستمرين وزخمهم يعني يستمر بين
الحين او يتصاعد بين الحين والاخر الاجانب
طبعا
الطلاب وهم ايضا يحتبرون همم يعني همم
الشريحه المثقفه الواعيه الشباب المتحمس
ايضا النظام الايراني تخوف من هؤلاء بشكل
كبير لانهم اثبتوا شجاعتهم ووعيهم في يعني
شال كل محاولات النظام الايراني القضاء
عليهم وعلى احتجاجات الجامعات ويدل على
فشل النظام الايراني في المجال التعليمي
وغسل الادمغه الطلاب لن ارادهم يكونون
اصوات للنظام لكن الان بداوا هم اصوات ضد
النظام واصوات الثوره اليوم في ايران هما
الطلاب
النقطه الاخرى التي تعتبر ايضا مهمه اليوم
خروج
ابنه همم اخ اخ من اي همم
والذي يعبر اليوم عن هذا الجناح الذي كنا
منذ بدايه هذه التظاهرات نعول عليه الجناح
الرافض المعارض الذي تم اساته اليوم خروج
هذا يعني هذه الاصوات الى العلم من جديد
الى اي ماده ممكن ان تضعف النظافه
اكيد يعني عندما اقرباء العائله الخامنيهم
يخرجون ضد خامني ويرفضون النظام برمته
بهذا يعني ان هناك تاكل بدا ايضا يتسع
ويتعمق في النظام ايراني وفي جسد النظام
عندما يكون يعني هؤلاء المقربون
والمنتفعون بشكل عام يصطفون الى
الشعوب في داخل ايران يصطفون الاجانب
الثوره بمعنى هذه الثوره الحقيقيه قد بدات
بمعنى انه لا شخص مقرب ولا يعني غير مقربه
هو اراضا عن خامني وعن استبداده بالاضافه
الى هؤلاء لا ننسى انه الحركه المهمه التي
ايضا بدات تتعمق وتتوسع هي الاحتجاجات
والاضرابات
للسوائل الشاحنات سواق الشاحنات وايضا
العمال بدات ايضا تستمر بشكل كبير جدا
وهذا ما يضعف ايضا النظام ايراني بشكل
كبير وخاصه الجانب الاقتصادي وسيدسبب
باشلاء بشل الاقتصاد الايراني اذا ما
استمر هؤلاء وخاصه هم ليس فقط يرفضون
النظام ايراني واداءه بل هم جواع لانه بعض
همم عن السواق لم يستلموا رواتبهم منذ
تسعه شهور وهذا حال الكثير من القطاعات
العماليه والسواق وغير ذلك لانه النظام
الايراني يعني هذا الاموال الهائله بدل ان
يعطيها للعمال واستحققات العاملين يصرف
عليهم
شكرا لك استاذ حسن راديو البحث في شان
ايراني حدثنا منه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
تركيا تقصف شمال سوريا مجددا
[موسيقى]
لم تهدا الاحداث في منطقتنا حتى يومنا هذا
واليوم قبل ان يستريح العالم بعد جائعه
طالت البشريه جمعاء تفجرت ازمات جديده
ولكن هذه المره على مستوى العالم
كم هائل من الاحداث والمعلومات يتدفق كل
يوم اخبار حروب وتداعيات سياسيه واقتصاديه
اصبح ما بين السطور اكثر من السطور
ابعد جديده تستدعي اسلوبا جديدا وتحليلا
ادق تصور مختلف لعالم يبدو اكثر تسارعا كل
يوم
البعد الاخر مع منتهى الرمحي السبت 11:30
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
رحله الى عالم اخر سنمزجه فيه الافتراضي
والمعسل كلمات معقده جدا
نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره كامله
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
العسكريه شمال سوريا بهدف اقامه حزام
الامني من الغرب الى الشرق على طول الحدود
الجنوبيه لتركيا لابقاء الحدود امنه كما
تقول وفي التفاصيل الميداليه استهدفت
الضربات الجويه التركيه مطار العسكري
وقرى بريف حلب الشمالي وفقه طبعا المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان الذي اكد ان السلاح
الجوي التركي يواجه ضربات جويه مكثفه عبر
الطيران الحربي والطائرات المسيره
للمقاتلين الاكراد ومن الارض المدعيه
التركيه تطلق القذائف بشكل مكثف وعنيف على
المقاتلين الاكراد في شمال سوريا
225 شخصا خلال خمسه ايام من القارات
الجويه التركيه على المناطق الكرديه بشمال
سوريا وزاره الدفاع التركيه اعلنت مقتل
اثنين من مسلحا من حزب العمال الكردستاني
شمالي سوريا والعراق خلال اليومين
الاخيرين في ظل استمرار التحديدات التركيه
هذا هو اعلنت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قصد
وقف عملياتها ضد تنظيم داعش مشدده على
انها ستتصدى لاي عمل بري تركي ماذا فعل
الى دخول تعزيزات عسكريه ضخمه لقوات
التحالف الدولي في مناطق شمال وشرق سوريا
قادمه من اقليم كردستان العراق المشهد في
شمال سوريا عارضته واشنطن بشده حيث طالبت
انقره في وقفه عملياتها العسكريه وروسيا
بدورها اعربت عن امالها بوقف التصعيد
التركي
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الماليه الفرنسيه
ربما تحاول التفاوض على بعض الاعفاءات من
الرسوم والقيود الوارده في قانون
امريكيون ان حزمه الدعم الهائله التي تهدف
لحمايه المصنعين الامريكيين قد توجه ضربه
قاتله للصناعاتهم التي تعاني بالفعل في ظل
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه الناجمه عن الحرب
زارا رائد الفضاء الامريكي سكوت كلي اطفال
مرضى
اضافه الى اطفال جرحى نتيجه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا وذلك في احد مشافي العاصمه
الاكرانيه كياب وادانا كلى الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا ووصفه بانه غير قانوني وغير
اخلاقي الفن نتابع
هناك كثير
ان هذا الغزوه خطا انه غير اخلاقي وغير
قانوني
مره اخرى تظهر علنا ابنه الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي كيم جون
والتقت هذه المره بعلماء صواريخ
ووصفت بالقاب اكثر تشريفا مثل الطفله
المحبوبه او الغاليه وتبلغ ابنتك من العمر
حوالي 10 اعوام فقط لكن صورها الجديده
والجريئه تعمق الجدل حول ما اذا كانت تعد
كخليفا لوالدها وفقا لاسوشيت بريس
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه معنا
دخول الملاعب دون شراء التذاكر مسبقا
العربيه نقلت لكم الصوره
يحدد جوجل وابل بصناعه هواتف منافسه اذا
حذفت وتر من متاجر تطبيقات ابل واندرويد